good morning everybody it is a little
past 9 30 and we're gonna start the work
session on House Bill 105. I'd like to
introduce representative leckis and
representative Bailey who are members of
our subcommittee this morning and we
have representative grassy and
representative Fitzpatrick
um so
we had a lively hearing on House Bill
105 and as a result of
the input that we had from the hearing
it was decided that we might try to
amend the bill and went through
different iterations of it
and I am introducing to the subcommunity
amendment which essentially takes out
section two
I only use section one and creates um
a record retention
for seven years for the hospitals
and for birth centers
um
so I'm going to pass this out to sub
actually representative Bailey will you
do that
you've got one
that said
um that said
um we did speak with the secretary of
state and with um Department of Health
and Human Services we would like to
continue looking at section two of the
bill and work over and work on it over
the summer so that we can
um
um address similar concerns that people
have about privacy
it was discussed there was a senate
hearing yesterday on the um on the bill
and an amendment was offered to transfer
the vital records from the Secretary of
State to the Department of Health and
Human Services and it was not accepted
by the committee and it was opposed by
the Secretary of State's office so
um
based on the fact that our constitution
says Secretary of State actually is
there someone here from the Secretary of
State's office would you like to speak
on that
just so that we every everybody's on the
same page because typically what happens
before subcommittees is we have all
these conversations so I would love to
have somebody from the Secretary of
State's office explain this
good morning uh thank you very much for
calling us up my name is Aaron Hennessey
I am the deputy secretary of state and
with me today
I'm Kristen kenniston I am the new State
Registrar
so in new thank you for the question
about the Constitution so in New
Hampshire's constitution in part second
article 68 it says that the records of
the state shall be kept in the office of
the secretary
um the
um this includes the vital records in
the state and that's under uh RSA 5 C
um colon 3 the policy in the
um and state law does identify the
Secretary of State as The Keeper of the
records of the state and includes
um the records of Vital Records and the
data associated with that and I also
want to emphasize that our our state law
says that we are the keepers of the
records but also while assuring the
privacy of all New Hampshire citizens so
that's the Privacy piece is something
that we take very seriously in addition
to the vital records of the state we are
the keeper of all records of the state
this includes all the records for all
the um the physical records we have
over a hundred thousand boxes that we
keep in our division of archives and
Records management
and that that number grows annually
um as as well as the number of
electronic records that we maintain for
the state continues to grow
um
I'm sorry if I'm continuing on and too
far down a rabbit path about
um about what the records management
that we do for the state is
in the conversation that we had was that
over the summer we would meet with your
office so that the
concerns that people have of a privacy
are addressed and
um that the records are useful for
individuals and for but at the same time
and for other organizations but at the
same time
yes the privacy of our of our citizens
projected yes um and we are happy to
meet with the committee um whenever you
would like over the summer we're here
all year round so whatever works for you
works for us and we're happy to
um to show you
um take you to Vital Records we we won't
show you any of the private information
but we and we will
um we can we have a vault there that of
actual physical records but we can chat
with you about the actual privacy and
how we do that within the department and
I'm sure that DHHS can
um share that with you from when the
information is transferred to them as
well do you have a question
representative
okay do we have any questions from the
committee yes
thank you madam chair
um so I've already shared my concerns
with uh some of your people uh Madam
Secretary uh
um and I don't know whether uh we're
going to have an opportunity to uh to
talk about
your thinking in in response to
um in response to some of the concerns
that I've raised I I I I don't know
whether that's been communicated to you
I've been talking with director Tilly
Miss Rogers
whom I know from my time on the vital
records privacy board so the so the the
question is whether uh you have some
proposals because uh if if you've heard
discussed my concerns with them which I
suppose you have
then you know that I'm looking for some
uh assuredness that uh that uh that One
Bad Apple cannot get into a situation
where the the very conscientious and
incompetent work of both the Secretary
of State's office but also DHHS to keep
these privacy concerns uppermost in your
eye and your mind when you're dealing
with people's confidential and very
often sensitive information I I served
for uh something like five or six years
on the vital records privacy board so I
know the issues well I'm I'm not blind
to the tremendous need for this data to
be available and the screening that's
being done that that is protected uh
newborns from very very serious medical
complications uh if left unrecognized
and unattended to
um so I understand the value of
statistical data and so forth so on by
the same token that questionnaire that
has the name the address all the
identifying aspects has also all that
sensitive information on it and that in
itself to the degree and that has to be
processed by a human being
that can't be processed by a computer
because you have to put it all into the
system then you can segregate out the
information that that doesn't need to be
part of the identity doesn't make any
difference in terms of disease or
something the disease or medical issues
that's something for the doctors for the
medical side
the statistical side is something for
the statisticians but that questionnaire
that has all the information and the
especially the identity before it's
de-identified that's that's potentially
uh and and I know because I haven't had
personal experience but in my career as
a legislator I've had experience with
situations where bad apples have
betrayed their trust and had devastating
impact on certain situations so that's
that's what I'm concerned about whether
there's not some way to further reduce
because I understand the sincerity and
the protections that are out there and I
respect that the problem is
uh to the degree that somebody violates
the confidentiality and the trust of the
public and the presumably take an oath
or something like that to to maintain
those uh those standards
um to the degree they betray that
now the damage is done and we've we've
seen it in the field of Espionage right
one spy betrays the whole system uh and
so to the degree that that you are
thinking and your your colleagues are
thinking about further ways to protect
people's privacy so that embarrassing uh
information but nevertheless vital for
the system to know uh cannot be attached
to
left attached uh to the to the person's
name
if you can do that that would be very
helpful in my view so thank you
don't believe this if there's any other
questions so this time and um
representative Schmidt we agreed that we
would hold a um an in I'm going to call
an informal study Edna is going to have
is going to meet with the Department the
Secretary of State and the Department of
Health and Human Services to address
your concern
um would you like to would would someone
from DHHS like to
speak we have a question for someone in
particular somebody who has an interest
in this from
using the data for medical research
and other related things
good morning my name is Trisha Tilley
I'm the director of Public Health good
morning my name Isola I'm the bureau
chief of Public Health statistic
informatics
okay thank you um as representative
groda said we're looking you know the
Privacy part we plan on
removing for now and then looking at
working on that over the summer but I
have a question if you don't have a good
answer to it now that's fine you can
give it later and that is
um you know the the bill as it came out
of the senate had no address information
provided which you know the public
hearing we heard was a problem because
then the only location information would
be where the birth occurred and that
wasn't
granular enough an area to be useful on
the other hand you know there's a number
of us concerned about privacy who really
have a problem with the actual address
being provided and find that
problematic let's just say the question
is if the data that was provided didn't
have the full address but the ZIP code
would that be granular enough for the
research and other purposes that you'd
want the data for
so thank you for the questions first of
all DHHS under the statue is responsible
for releasing health related research
under the
approval of under the vital record
privacy board so each individual
application including the continuous use
of the data will need to go to the about
the record vital record privacy board
excuse me for review and approval in
terms of the data elements that are
selected in the application based on the
study needs the board members look into
each individual elements and
submit the questions or have a questions
on whether the justification is is good
enough I understand that but what the
question is
um if the data that was I mean the
Secretary of State's office will get
data required for uh to create a birth
certificate on whatever that is and I
know there's a problem with the bill as
I meant by the senate in that regard but
if we had a bill that did not make the
actual address data available at all
and if the DHHS I mean if server State
Vital Records these are for the birth
certificate they would get it
um but it would not go beyond that to
anyone under any circumstances and the
question is if that were not available
at all
um you know would that be would you
still have enough data to do useful
research
I would say no because we do need to
have full addresses not just for
research but for our internal
um program purpose like you you may
heard on newborn screening we do need to
have the address in order to match the
person but back to the research um
question it depends on the research
study design if the study design is
um to look into each individual with the
interview they do need to have the
actual address in order to perform this
kind of study so it really based on
depends on the study design and and
whether the study will need to do record
by record to have those four or partial
personal identifiers for their research
and and I would just add
um as um mentioned not only is there a
concern around the studies and the
health component of this but also the
department would require that address
information for other areas of the
department for functions within our
division of economic supports within our
Medicaid fraud investigation there are
other opportunities within the
department where the at where the
address is really important so I think
that that's a perfect thing for us to
talk about in the summer to drill down
to more detail
um okay thank you I think representative
look is
that's why we want to understand how all
this information is used because it's
all
it sort of spins out into different
things and we have to be will we have to
understand what it's being used for and
then it's our it's our discretion
whether or not we that's the issue just
one one related thing and that is
um
I mean hopefully you have you know
control where the data goes and
therefore hopefully you have an idea of
what all this data is used for so if
you could put something together if it
doesn't already exist saying each one of
these data elements and what are they
actually used for thank thank you we've
begun that developing that table to
understand and you know I think Dave
Wieters and others can provide a robust
description of our access policy around
who can have access to what components
of the data for what business purpose so
we've begun that work we're happy to
share that as as we continue and and be
informed by what happens during the
settler study committee sure oh just
quick and that if you you know as you
put that together you have you know some
useful version of it if you could send
it to the committee so we can look at it
before we actually end up meeting so
thank you yes we've begun that certainly
from the health component what data
elements are For What and we're getting
a comprehensive list throughout the
department of which elements are used
for which program specifically okay
thank you
thank you madam chair representative I
just wanted to point out I live in a
community that technically shares a zip
code with another town and we are
separated by a river
uh obviously some of the environmental
issues on one side of the river would be
quite different than environmental
issues on the other side so I think just
using a zip code would not be effective
for even a study that's trying to keep
the individual Anonymous I I get that I
mean there's that and then there's also
um if you have a zip code with few
enough people then it's not effectively
anonymizing either so there's issues on
both sides and as representative said I
mean we need to understand how the data
is being used and then there needs to be
a a policy determination of the
trade-off between
what they want to use the data for and
people's right to having the data and
maybe you know people can opt in for
parts of it or whatever but we can try
and sort that out
yeah I get it
representative grassy yeah I'd just like
to point out additionally in this case
is that a lot of times we need that
address data because when particularly
when you're looking at a case of
contamination of a well or a spillage or
something if without that data you're
unable to pinpoint The Source you can
say it's a zip code but that's in a
whole community and if it's just a a
dump site in one area that's causing a
problem with premature or low birth
weights or diseases that children are
having
um at Birth you know they're finding at
Birth for these children we try to
identify the source and without having
addresses you can't identify that source
there's a lot of issues we'll have to
look at so
Schmidt
so what is the what is your intention
Madam chair with regard to uh processing
the bill because uh you know it was made
pretty clear to us in the initial
hearing that the the bill as amended by
the Senate just doesn't work
in a totality anyway
um a birth certificate with no name of
the child no name of the parents no
address is not a birth certificate it's
just an interesting statistic
but who this is is kind of like a
mystery so uh clearly the bill can't go
forward in my view in this fashion so
what is your intention with regard to
voting this out so the subcommittee has
been presented an amendment which I
emailed to the committee subcommittee
yesterday which I just gave to you this
is your Amendment you're referring to
and um it takes it it um
basically uh includes the
decriminalization of entering your birth
weight incorrectly
um
and and it matters like that it does
limit the retention of birth worksheets
at both the hospital and
home births birthing centers for up to
seven years
and that's essentially the bill over the
course of the summer our committee will
meet with DHHS and the department and
Secretary of State and we'll you know
we'll drill down into the data
so that we understand any kind of
privacy concerns that we might have
and either put in legislation or not I
don't know what the committee will
decide representative grassy yeah one of
the questions I had and I'm glad to feel
folks from dhhsa here is that if we
limit this data for seven years and at
that time that data would be disposed of
um would that limit your ability to
probably track illnesses which may not
manifest themselves in the first five or
six years of of a child's life but would
show up later in life
actually okay I it's just that the birth
center and Hospital doesn't have to keep
it vital records would keep it
indefinite so the data is still there
it's just who has okay I just want to
make sure that somebody's keeping that
data and and we're able to fall back on
that debt or if we need it it
s privacy and security of the data that
you don't have data sitting in another
location indefinitely it would just
simply require Secretary of State's
office to maintain the data and we would
maintain the data along with our data
retention policies
okay so I have a question on this all
the records that the birth centers and
the hospitals are keeping now
do they have does this allow them to
delete that data how is that what's the
um
what would the hospital do with the mvs
hi
[Laughter]
so I just don't want it to appear in a
dumpster someplace I'm sure there must
be some sort of record retention or
record deletion but I'd like to know
what that is
good morning Madam chair um for the
record Paula minahan Hospital
Association this um the seven years
coincides with current law relative to
the requirements of hospitals to
maintain records so that and I did talk
with um deputy secretary Hennessy this
morning so that this is fine the seven
years we're we're fine with that
um and yes
um after that they what typically
happens my understanding is they
actually
um
um put it in in their own archives um or
they may actually
um delete it but they don't have to hold
the actual record in their in their EMR
in their electronic medical record after
seven years but this is consistent with
current state law
okay thank you does anyone have any
other questions
representative Locust I just wanted to
confirm that the way this is worded
would allow
hospitals and birth centers to get rid
of all the back data that's you know
more than seven years old right
believe so I probably I you know what I
should check with um experts at the
hospitals to confirm that I will this is
the first I'm seeing of this actual
language so let me verify that but I
believe that that is the case they could
eliminate it okay another question I
mean the uh the data the records that
are kept
uh now and would continue to be kept
really seven years I mean those are they
entirely or for the most part kept an
electronic form or they're actually
paper records electronic primarily yep
okay yeah but it's it's all part of a
lot of this data is in the um electronic
medical record now okay yeah I think and
I assume any personal data that uh has
gotten rid of that happens to be in
paper form is appropriately yes they
follow
um very strict HIPAA
um requirements federal and state law
relative to privacy yes all right thank
you
where we have another minute or so uh so
I my understanding is that New Hampshire
is quite different from the rest of the
country in terms of basically it's 49
states on one side and New Hampshire on
the other with regard to the fact that
we have stuff being held by our
Secretary of State's office uh that is
is handled differently in other states
but that that our system it works at
least as well or perhaps even better
um and are we are we looking at what
other states are doing with the with a
view to to get to getting closer to them
if their system is better uh or can you
speak to that I mean Paulie you may not
be the person I don't believe I'm the
right person to answer that
well then maybe somebody would be the
right person
does anybody want to answer that do they
is there anyone who can
nope okay well we'll keep that one for
the summer
that's fine by me as long as we're not
leaving it lying there nope nope nope in
the Dustbin never make just a quick
comment and uh one difference about New
Hampshire is we actually have in the
state constitution something that
specifies where the records are kept so
that is a real I think that's major
reason why it is different here
okay I'd like to move Amendment
2023-1728h
may I have second
Chuck okay
is there a further discussion on the
amendment I just have a question
procedurally representative grassy is
not listed on the subcommittee is is he
entitled to he's here yes because he is
representing representative Wilhelm and
there is a the paperwork hasn't been
updated but he is on the subcommittee
questions
is this the section one or two yes which
would then eliminate all of them no
no say this is it it keeps this and
eliminates all this that's right yeah
okay but we're decriminalizing that's
right okay
so
um
okay Amendment 2023
1728 h
is there a discussion
no call those in favor
opposed
okay
no that's okay and then um I move OTP
and move that we recommend
otpa to the committee
may I have a second
all those in favor
opposed okay
thank you this concludes the
subcommittee unless anybody else wants
to share something else I'm going to
close the hearing subcommittee Workshop
okay
thank you
hi everybody it's 11 o'clock so we're
going to start the work session on
oplc
organization
um on November on November cheese on May
22nd we will have a hearing on a
non-germane amendment that we're going
to put together based on the committee
work that's been done in work sessions
um I wanted to
um
I have a list of things that I've been
keeping track of and I wanted to
go over several of the things that have
been brought forth to our committee
and
um Mr dejoy
is here because one of the
something that he'd like to see is the
and we we've received a lot of notes a
lot of emails is about the social
workers compact which is
something that we could add
to us to a bill if we wanted to as part
of that Amendment
um so I asked him to he's here to answer
any questions that the committee might
have on
social workers compact so there is there
anything is there anyone that wants to
ask a question about that
no
well how it was a bill that we oh my
goodness hang on sorry
it wasn't yeah it was it a bill Senate
bill
it was representative Shapiro's Bill
House Bill 428
we retained and we could attach to
um we could include it I mean I I have
an issue with the compacts in general
yes and I know uh that representative
McGuire does as well but I don't have
any specific questions I don't think
about this one okay does anyone else
have any
okay so
um
do you have any new information or
things that might prompt people to ask
questions about the social workers
compact
thank you madam chair I'd like to think
I can say things that would prompt
people to ask questions but it's a
pretty high bar to reach what I would
say is that you've all received
information from social workers in the
state we asked our members to reach out
to you not with a form letter but to
explain to you how this compact would in
fact impact their practice and so that's
what we've asked them to give you I
think as you can see from the volume of
the correspondence you receive this is
an important issue for social workers
that's why this compact has come forward
that's why we've brought it Forward
outside of regular order where it would
have been introduced as a as a piece of
legislation
it's so important for portability of
licenses for being bringing social
workers into the state it's important
for military families it's important for
our members who live on state borders
and may have to maintain multiple
licenses to work in Vermont
Massachusetts and New Hampshire and New
Hampshire and Maine and it's an
expensive proposition as well as a
time-consuming proposition
in terms of I know folks have asked for
data and I have shared data regarding
the nurse Practice Act and that there
was a 25 increase following the compact
introduction and acceptance 25 increase
in the availability of nurse
practitioners in this state we reached
out to the Council on state governments
they have been coordinating this effort
Nationwide they've held the meetings in
D.C they're the ones who helped to bring
all the states together to put this
forward we asked them for this data and
they indicated that that's one of the
problems is that there is no data in in
the country regarding the impact of some
of these practices
what I will say and I understand
director Courtney will be here a little
bit later what she has said to me not to
put words in her mouth is that the compa
and she negotiated this compact on
behalf of New Hampshire the compact for
social workers as put together is very
similar to the nurse
um compact
in that it is a true multi-state license
so when social workers are licensed in
New Hampshire
and they go to another state they can
begin practicing
they don't need to apply for a new
license when a social worker moves to
this state from any other compact state
they can also begin practicing in New
Hampshire has significant impact on
Telehealth the portability of of clients
being able to keep their
um their clinicians if they're in
college if they move to a different
state
so it has a lot of significant impacts
on practice and finally I would point
out that last last session this
committee adopted the Mental Health
compact
by a pretty strong vote
a number of you were here a number of
you weren't here the reason I raised
that is that the Mental Health
Counselors are part of the same Board of
mental health practice that social
workers are
with one specialty having a compact and
another specialty not having a compact
it puts social work as a competitive
disadvantage in terms of the field and
the portability of the licensure I won't
get into again the benefit of being one
of the first few States I've talked
about that I'd be happy to answer
questions on that but that's what I have
to add
okay thank you I think we're that's what
we have what we need thanks
um so on my I'm just looking at the
things that are easy to um discuss one
of them has to do with
um in the in Statue it doesn't state
that mental health boards have to have
public members that are independent from
the practice of mental health so we are
going to put language in that and I've
asked oplc to make sure that all the
other boards have that Clause to be sure
that board members
the public board members of any of the
boards at oplc are independent so that
will be something that will be we will
be putting on the non-germaine amendment
um the other
has to do with a career ladder for lnas
there was um
lnas are an entry-level type of of a
position in the field and we'd like to
see what kind of advancement could be
made between an LNA and a full
practicing nurse so that there's a
career path for women for I'm sorry for
um individuals who are men and women who
are lnas that's something that will be
in the amendment
um the other has to do with
um
I'm going to telemedicine and it's um an
amendment that representative McGuire
which which allows telemedicine or
Telehealth anyone practicing
um
in New Hampshire be registered license
or or certified
by the licensing body body
um
before they can do that so that's going
to be so that will ex that will
basically cover telemedicine for all
practices
um
the um
we don't think that
um
we need the merging of the mental health
boards which is something that had been
in House Bill 2 that we had looked at we
believe that the language and the
amendment to House Bill 655 is
um addresses that
there is
um a concern though for making sure that
we have strict delineation between
investigation and adjudication which is
something
attorney osterhout do you have a comment
to make about that
because I know that so recently in our
one of our house bills
there is a senate amendment that defines
allegations and
complaints
so I just want to make sure that
whatever we do doesn't
you know that we have some some
continuity between those things if any
good morning Douglas sauser how general
counsel for oplc I have a comment but I
I don't know how helpful it is so we
just came
from the hearing on Senate Edna on HB in
amendment to HB uh 532 532 and there was
testimony on both sides on that very
specific issue
and they were working on draft Amendment
language so right now I don't know what
that looks like until I see and that's
that's where executive director Courtney
is right now she's over
across the street
so whatever changes
I just want to make sure that we don't
Collide or
step over each other I think Crossing
amendments I agree with that and I but I
don't know what's going to be in the
amendment at the end of the day it's is
the issue so I think it's something once
we see that Amendment language we can
flag it and and make sure everything
works together appropriately and who's
writing that Amendment language you know
it's not me
I don't know I'll check okay
um
the other
and those are really this the main
points that I wanted to make we do we
are going to be sure that there's that
there's a in statute a delineation
between adjudication and investigation
so that means that that will be clearly
defined and in-house Bill
655 there was a lot of
um
there were a lot of changes to
disciplinary actions on the part of the
board so we want to make sure that that
language is
promptly identifies who's responsible
for what
yes representative yes yeah one thing I
was just looking at a houseboat 655 so I
guess the senate committee
their recommendation was ought to pass
without any Amendment and I believe the
Senate will be voting on that tomorrow
so we you know so we know what probably
know what that's going to be
could change but we should know in a day
um
and then looking at your list I mean
there's some other minor ones Telehealth
for Pas I guess we managed to leave them
out
I think what we do with telemedicine and
Telehealth on in number nine at the
bottom will address them
yeah
we still have to another issue within
the oplc realm is the medical review
subcommittee
which do we want to put that in the
non-germain amendment or do we want to
wait until we have more time over the
summer and I see rep I see director
Courtney is here don't sit down too soon
okay I have a question yeah I'm I know
I'm not really clear on what the medical
review subcommittee does what it is
well maybe that's that's a very good
question and maybe so can you explain to
the group what the medical review
subcommittee is yes and how we need to
address the issues with that so with
that group certainly thank you and I
apologize for being late I was at the
Senate um
so the medical review subcommittee is a
body that's created in statute it's
comprised of primarily Physicians but
also I believe a PA and some public
members they are appointed by governor
and Council so they're they're
independent of the Board of Medicine and
their charge is to essentially
investigate claims
um there have been issues with the MRC
reaching Quorum
um I think in the last year they've met
50 of the time
and the
individual members on the MRC have
reported that they are only able to
review
um about one case per month we receive
over 200 a year so doing the math
obviously that doesn't work
um which has created a backlog we have
worked uh with the Board of Medicine to
create some sort of uh work around a
different process to the extent that we
can through statute to move these cases
along but there Still Remains a backlog
my suggestion and I believe in Dr Baker
from the Board of Medicine is here
um I believe the Board of Medicine has
voted on this but my suggestion is to
proceed with a non-germaine Amendment
eliminate the mrsc establish the ability
and rule for the Board of Medicine to
establish an investigative committee
that is accountable to them because
that's the other issue here is once
you're on there's no way to get you off
other than going through the impeachment
process even if you aren't able to
attend and satisfy Quorum I think time
is of the essence given that we have
cases that are backed up that are ready
to be reviewed and are just waiting to
go through this process and we would
support a non-termain Amendment sooner
rather than later
and representative schwart has a
question
thank you director
um you stated that the review board is
only handling one case a month
approximately uh in your opinion why is
that
so they've reported that they can review
each each member can review only one
case per month because of the time
commitments
um
which is just not
sufficient with what we need to do in an
investigation
sorry about that
um
so do you know what the logic was for
creating the separate medical review
subcommittee when it was created in the
statute yes I would divert a Dr Baker
more on that one but my understanding is
it stemmed from an audit I believe in
2012 and it had to do with separating
the duties the investigative duties from
the adjudicating duties which we fully
support that's very consistent with what
655 proposes and the Board of Medicine
also supports that I will say that the
Board of Medicine more than probably
most regulatory boards is very cognizant
of their need to separate those two
functions the issue here is how it's
been implemented and the fact that
there's no accountability if they were
able to establish a committee and Rule
theoretically they could promulgate
rules that would set forth the
membership requirements such that oh if
you missed three meetings or off and we
you know you can appoint somebody else
and that seems to be the issue
so how does
so if a complaint comes in about a
concerning a doctor then it goes to the
medical review subcommittee first is
that
how it's supposed to work how it how
it's working now is that we receive a
complaint the the office will review to
determine whether or not it states it
states a claim of professional
misconduct
um if it does not we send it over to our
physician investigator which is a
contracted physician if he agrees we
send it over to the Board of Medicine
and the Board of Medicine can dismiss
um if if the office and the physician
investigator agree that the complaint
States a claim it gets assigned to an
mrsc member we'd like that MRC member to
work directly with staff because staff
are in a position to conduct interviews
gather records that hasn't really
fleshed out at this point in time the
MRC largely relies on record review and
not necessarily interviews and other
investigative processes so we're still
working through that because this
process is fairly new in our attempt
kind of get through this backlog and
work around not around but be creative
with the statutory requirements but um
but that's essentially the process now
so
um would the language in HP 655 change
this at all
well that's an interesting question
representative
um and we haven't flushed it out legally
um because it does appear to conflict
with the Board of Medicine practice act
so I think one could take the position
that if 655 were to to pass and it
conflicts uh with the establishment of
the mrsc at 655 supersedes that and the
Board of Medicine doesn't necessarily
need to utilize the MRC the problem is
um from the and I don't want to speak
for the board but I understand the
board's concern is that they do want an
investigative
body comprised of peers to assist staff
and that's the issue so MRC does fulfill
that function when it's working and if
we were to rely it's only on 6 55 we
wouldn't have that investigative body of
peers
um okay and so if you end up with a as I
understand a subcommittee of the Board
of Medicine doing this
is that end up creating a conflating the
investigatory and adjudicary uh
functions I don't think so the way we
envision it is that we would pair staff
investigators up with a number
and a peer review investigator if you
will
um many cases don't require expertise
you know the you know I don't I don't
like my Jello case or
um somebody murdered me case you know
that may not be something that requires
medical expertise
um but a lot of cases do and so what
we'd like to do is pair them up with a
physician investigator and have them
basically work the case up in tandem
Physicians by training you know are not
necessarily graded interviewing
Witnesses they may be fantastic but they
may not feel comfortable so that's why
the staff expertise comes in and staff
on the other hand don't have the
expertise of a physician so we think
that collaboration is important
okay thank you
okay representative
thank you madam chair um represented uh
represented sorry director in your
experience have you seen complaints
that would
possibly cross the line it's where it's
difficult to determine whether it would
require
expertise in the field as opposed to
administrative problems or is it pretty
clear-cut
I would
I would say it's pretty clear I mean
it's this same legal standard that
applies to any simple case as to whether
expertise is required or not
um
so you know and and we do have curious
if it's possible to craft something that
would
specifically delineate one as opposed to
the other
possibly I mean I think that's why we
have the physician investigator too
because I'll give you an example sexual
assault that to me off the top of its
head may not seem to be something that
requires expertise however if the
examination requires you to do X Y and Z
which is perceived by somebody to be an
assault but is actually standard of care
we wouldn't know that unless the
physician was able to open on that so
that's why I think it's important to
pair the two after talking in the
position The Physician could say yeah no
that's not an expertise that doesn't
require expert testimony
so what you're saying is that we will
replace the medical review subcommittee
with something like a peer review group
right yes and it's Dr Baker do you have
comments on that I think she's
foreign
I'm not good at this I think I got it
this time hit the button right
yeah the the boards interest is to have
like every separated for the the video
could you please identify yourself I
apologize I'm Emily Baker I'm the
current president of the Board of
Medicine I'm a practicing obstetrician
gynecologist up in Lebanon
and
I mean the functions that we support are
separating adjudication and
investigation which is a function
has been in the past super effective by
the by the mrse and Dr irum represented
executive director Courtney
actually told you what's going on now
so the two things we have talked about
is
it's we it's not really a peer review
committee necessarily because it's going
to have public we prefer public members
to be on it
and the investigation would then come to
this group and just like this
deliberative body you work on the
collective wisdom
of the individuals who've done the
expertise can present to the board their
opinion and the board doesn't
necessarily agree
we've had stuff come to us where they
said do discipline and we didn't we've
had some the other way around where we
said nope discipline is really important
from this so is
having a group
the can look at the investigations done
that have been done with the assistance
of the staff
and then
look at each of them and use the
collective wisdom of the group to come
up with a recommendation for the board
okay so this actually
is very similar to what we're going to
be doing with other boards whereas oplc
is going to be doing the investigation
because they're going to be the
investigatory arm and the boys will have
a disciplinary and what we're saying is
that in to help the oplc do the
investigation
there will be Physicians who they work
in tandem with and will those is that is
that I see everybody well see some
people shaking their heads so I'm
thinking that this okay so how do we put
that in statute
you have a question yeah I do and that
is um
my understanding and I'm trying to see
if my understands correct from uh what
director Courtney said was that this
peer review group would be made up of a
subset of the members of the board is
that correct or not
no
um it and I think it's important in
order to keep the functions separate
um that they would be people appointed
by the board
um and I we have some draft language
that would essentially give the board
rulemaking authority to establish this
committee and I think you could make
that statutory a change in their
existing rulemaking Authority
okay
one of the the things that's important
when we look at both of these bodies is
to make sure there's a distribution of
different kinds of Specialties if you
have six cardiologists to get nowhere
and it's true both for the current mrsc
and what we would any group we would
have to work carefully at the membership
to make sure there's adequate
distribution of expertise
to be able to
form recommendations to the board for
discipline for
confidentials letter of concern or
dismissal so would all that be in rule
making okay because I want to make sure
that
we what concerns me is that the Board of
Medicine will be appointing the people
to the
um
whatever this thing is called let's just
call it a peer review
and um I just want to make sure that
there's no
relationship let's just say between the
Board of Medicine and those people that
are appointed to this board that's
supposed to be independent so how do we
kind of how is that create that yeah
yeah that's right too yeah that's a good
that's a good
um
that's a good point you could have and I
I don't want to speak out of turn
without thinking but you could have a
process where the oplc has to also
approve of the of the appointed person
such that if there was
you know theoretically I want to appoint
my brother
um we we could object and not approve it
you could have I mean we've seen that in
other statutes I would say mechanical
statute has a similar Arrangement not
with respect to
appointments but with respect to
actually there's his fees and other
certain charges that mechanical board
has where the board is able to perform
certain functions with the approval of
the executive director you could phrase
it like that if you wanted some
um you know additional
is the stat is the mechanical board
process in statute or is it in general
making
well the mechanical board I just
referenced the fact that there's a
two-step process it's not it doesn't
have anything to do with committees it
actually has to do with fees
um and other rules that they enact but
the language is there such that there's
a little bit more oversight
um that you could you could allow for in
this circumstance as well
so before you came to the meeting I just
want to make sure that
you understand that I told the group
that we're going to have a hearing on a
non-germaine Amendment regarding these
things on the 22nd
so we need to have the language like
lickety-split in OLS so that we can put
together an a non-germaine Amendment
that's going to address the disciplinary
actions of boards versus the
adjudication right and that we're going
to have the LNA career ladder
amendment that we're going to address
telemedicine Telehealth and telemedicine
for professionals including Pas because
that's part of it
um
we can and I don't know if
um we're going to be able to
get this bit of it done by then what do
you think
I think this you could get done we could
have done this afternoon it's actually I
think it's a pretty small statutory
change
um with respect to the peer review only
the other items I think are a little bit
more involved which those items are the
LNA piece
um the PA Telehealth
is was proposed in an amendment that's
before the Senate right now on 532. okay
so it is possible that that's going to
be covered elsewhere it's actually in
two amendments
um I know that the veterinarians and
naturopathic doctors have also asked for
a similar change that's also likely
going to be included in those amendments
before the Senate
um and that was on the music therapy
bill
um I think the L A Piece is going to be
the one that takes a little bit more
time okay but we're okay with doing the
um reorganizing the disciplinary action
portion of of other boards
so that was remember that was part that
was in how the original bill of House
Bill 655 and we took that out to but we
intended to put it back in as part of
our non-germana method so I just want to
make sure
that we have something beefy after all
this work are you talking about the
proposed repeals representative yeah we
that's that's okay something we already
have in writing we could okay that to
the committee and we want to make sure
that um all public members are
independent when they're on boards
because it's not specific in the Mental
Health Board statute
yes you might have to make the specific
change in the mental health statute if
we wanted to do it
um
the easy way that would require cleanup
you could just do a modification in our
statute and clean it up later that'd be
something that we'd have to look at
okay
I guess whatever we need to get done by
the time that
addresses the disciplinary actions it
repeals of the disciplinary actions that
re that he makes sure that all public
members of all boards are independent
that we address this piece this medical
review piece
and that our licensing process is is
objective that there are no subjective
components to our licensing process
regardless of what the board is I just
want to make sure that's another thing
that we want that we that is in house
bill that was the intent of house bill
655. so those are four important things
and um I just want to be sure that we
get that language
and I'll be glad to help with that but I
need you to help me write it
um and I think that will take care of a
significant part of
there were some there were some language
in hospital 655 that was removed and one
of them was The Advisory board for
acupuncturists I know we have someone
you from is this no okay so I I thought
that the acupuncturist wanted to be and
wanted an Advisory Board they wanted I'm
sorry thank you Dr Baker there's
anything else
um I just want to make sure I think that
I'm almost positive that the acupuncture
award wanted to be an Advisory Board
because they want
oplc to address
disciplinary issues within that board am
I I think there were some
um
conflicting information from various
stakeholders and I also think there was
some confusion I know that attorney had
a conversation with the stakeholder
group and I believe it was the
association and after that they seemed
more amenable to becoming an Advisory
Board the only board that I'm aware of
that was interested
um and I don't know that they took an
official position
um I would rely on attorney in to
correct me but I think it was a nursing
home administrators were interested in
discussing it
um just based on
discomfort with the disciplinary process
but I'm not aware of that being talked
about
subsequently
nursing home administrators they were
originally in hb2 proposed to convert to
an Advisory Board
um
and did we put that back in or no no the
only Advisory Board that's in hb2 right
now is the assessing certification board
under 310c which is different from the
assessing Standards Board
under dra the assessing certification
board doesn't yet exist because they
don't have any members okay so I know
that this was a sort of a gefuffle that
happened right so the assessing standard
board
is going to be
we're going to take that out of house
bill 655 because they're supposed to be
under dra correct
the assessing Standards Board is under
dra and in 655 it has that board being
transferred over which we don't want
which we don't want one of the
Amendments before the Senate right now
Edna on 532 is going to address that
okay good
right now
yeah well it's an amendment to 650.
I don't think there can be amendment to
655 well sorry it's a non-germaine
Amendment that's being attached to house
the poor music therapist Bill and so um
administrator
so presumably if it has a later
effective date it's supersedes exactly
no okay exactly so the intent is not to
have a committee of conference on House
Bill 655. so that what we passed they
passed and whatever discussions we have
will be on bills that they attached
amendments to
um
and now the assessing so the assessing
certification board is addressed but the
assessing oh yeah the assessing
certification board is the one that
needs to go
back to oplc is that right
um so the way 635 is worded is it had
it had the transfer of the wrong board
so it proposed to transfer the assessing
Standards Board under I think 21
I'm going to mess up the citation but it
was the dra board
and we need the board that's established
under 310c to move over here
that I believe will be addressed in the
proposed amendment to House Bill 532.
okay so that switch is going to be
addressed in-house bill in in-house Bill
532 correct hopefully we won't have to
think about that correct
um in house bill to
the assessing certification board under
310c is the only board that remains in
House Bill 2 that's proposed to convert
to an Advisory Board
they don't want to be an Advisory Board
have they spoken with you about this so
I understand the assessing Standards
Board does not want this certification
board to be an Advisory board but the
certification board itself doesn't yet
exist so the certification board can't
obviously take a position uh okay
so how when will we when do you who is
responsible for appointing people to the
assessing certification board so that's
a governor and Council appointment we
did send out
um we had a meeting with dra
um regarding
soliciting applications
um we have an online application process
where we receive the information and
forwarded over to the governor's office
um my understanding is they did
communicate that to their licensees and
I think we've only received one
application
um and so that's one of the reasons I
believe that a lot of these smaller
boards were proposed to be converted to
advisory
um was basically because there's just
not a huge application pool to draw from
and the other thing I would know is that
the certification board itself or I'm
sorry the standing Standards Board which
is under dra is a quite large so you're
already trying to solicit people to seat
that board
um
so I think that was part of the thought
process behind converting them to an
Advisory Board
So speaking of that one of the things
that we've talked about is reducing the
number of members on boards right we
started that process
is that something else that we can do as
a non-germain Amendment
are there any boards that come to mind
that where we could reduce the number of
public members or the number of members
total in total so that the boards can
become more effective with a smaller
quorum
I think certainly some of the boards
um that are struggling with Quorum right
now uh should be considered to have a
reduction in members and or converting
to Advisory Board
okay so we'll talk about that okay
does the committee have any other
questions yes I just want to go back to
the medical review subcommittee part and
that is um
As I understood it the general idea is
that oplc would handle the investigation
and then the boards would do the
adjudication so
I I have similar concerns representative
Grodd I'm like
if that's the case you want to keep
things separate how does it make sense
for
the medical board even to be appointing
the people
on this I mean I don't know if there's
you know if oplc could find people or
some other thing but that just seems
not quite with the spirit of keeping
them separate so I'm just wondering what
the thought was behind that
so our thought process is we want to be
collaborative and I don't think that we
considered it from that angle um I don't
know that the Board of Medicine did
either
um from the agency's standpoint we would
um if the committee is concerned about
that I think what you could do is have
the board establish
what Specialties or what they need on
this committee and have oplc do the
actual appointments
um
you could bifurcate that arrangement to
make it crystal clear that the board
doesn't have any hands in making the
appointments I think from our
perspective what we just want is some
accountability and some ability to have
people uh transition off the board if
they're not being productive and
attending meetings okay yeah I mean that
seems like a separate thing which
certainly makes sense
um
one question on this board I mean
is this a volunteer thing are these
people paid how does this and is that
going to stay the same it's voluntary
um they do receive a small burdium I
think it's like a hundred dollars a
meeting obviously nowhere close to
reimbursing them for the cost of uh
losing
um a day's worth of work
um I think that's something that we
could explore uh I think that's also
something that could be addressed
through rulemaking you know what the
qualifications are what the what you
would receive for reimbursement and and
I would say that from from a litigation
standpoint it's not uncommon to pay
experts 250 to even a thousand dollars
an hour so I mean 100 a day or 100 a
meeting versus that I mean there's that
could be why we're having a hard time
and getting applicants
right I'm not pushing at this point in
the process to with not much time to do
something about this but maybe something
to
think about for the future I don't know
thank you
so when do you think we could have the
language for for these things
let me remind you of the list
I or I can certainly meet with you to
make sure that we
because we need I'd like to have the
language for this for the committee over
the next hearing on Friday Monday the
22nd well Monday to the 22nd is the
hearing language would need to be here
by the Friday before okay what day is
that the 18th
I'm terrible with Friday before the 22nd
the 19th to 19th
okay so that means that we needed to um
we needed to OLS by this 18th right I
hope there's no or the 17th
we'll figure it out okay okay that time
frame shouldn't be a problem okay good
is there anything else that the
committee wants to discuss at this time
any questions
yes representative Ashwood and
representative Schmidt
um yes I was just checking and I thought
I recalled a bill
that I think is going to help the boards
meet and that's houseville 308 in Senate
Judiciary which will allow some members
to attend remotely
um do you agree that that's likely to
help with this backlog on some of the
boards I think it would certainly help
um
yes I think if people could if more
people could attend remotely that would
certainly help
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so it seems to me
that the these investigatory situations
[Music]
um are
uh
I have a question about that because it
seems to me that that most of the things
are going to be involving things like
um substance abuse situations
or ethical situations I don't I don't it
doesn't seem to me that very often
you're going to have situations that
you're going to be investigating
plumbers that can't Plumb or
electricians that don't know that black
goes to Black and not to red and so
forth uh technical questions doctors
that don't know how to to uh you know
that you have to do X first and then Y
and not the other way around it it it it
you have must have some experience
already where uh you you know what
percentage of complaints involve people
who are simply incompetent in their
trade or profession and other people who
are have got other problems either
they're
they're they're bad billers uh or
they're bad record Keepers and so forth
uh it's more that they have
personal failings and therefore
it's going to involve how you set up the
the boards if the oplc is going to be
doing it clearly you're not going to
have expertise in how the professions in
other words how plumbers Plumb uh and
how uh OB gyns uh deliver babies
it's going to be about
ethical failings or
things like building maybe stealing from
uh from a client or customer and so
forth
and and you presumably have some
experience of this already so that you
have
uh because otherwise you're going to
have to have
only doctors know how to to to do the
medical side of things and electricians
know how to do the electrician side of
things
um so
it's going to be a big difference what
kind of an investigation you're going to
conduct no
I think it's very similar to how a civil
case is handled in the private practice
for example
um in a mental medical malpractice claim
lawyers work up the case lawyers don't
typically know medicine but they know
that they have to talk to other people
and they need to obtain the expert
qualifications in order to determine
whether there's been a violation of the
standard of care but the Physicians are
not running the investigation because
the Physicians know their their
expertise and their expertise only
they're not going to essentially depose
Witnesses and gather facts and so that's
how we handle our cases we get our our
case you know what is the complaint is
the complaint a substance use issue we
typically work with PHP professional
sales program if that's the issue is an
ethical violation
um if so maybe it's plainly stated what
the ethical violation is is and you
don't necessarily need expert testimony
or is it this person was grossly
negligent because pure negligence
typically won't get you there to
misconduct and if that's the case you
certainly need expertise on that and um
on the trades issue we don't see that a
lot but we do have inspectors in-house
and we always have the capability of
recusing a board member if we absolutely
need it as of late we've contracted a
lot before experts so that we don't need
to make those requests of various boards
but part of um
part of legal training and background is
to know what you don't know and when you
need expertise and what requires expert
qualifications and expert testimonies so
we are already utilizing that process to
some extent
follow-up on a different subject
so the thing is with regard to the
assessing Standards Board and the
assessing certification board
this was just a
screw up to put it bluntly where where
you know
the this was supposed to go
the assessing certification board was
supposed to be it was a brand new board
that was supposed to be set up under
oplc to handle
certification issues to some degree
disciplinary things
um and initial licensing things and the
assessing Standards Board was supposed
to stay with
dra where it had always been and instead
they got switched okay so the babies
went home with the wrong with the wrong
parents and so it but it should we I
think we should make sure that we have
input from the assessor who or somebody
who caught this mistake in the first
place
okay I think we've got it under control
thank you well it is under control but
only if we know that it was just a
simple
it was a complete goof it's a goof I I
know it's okay we're allowed we're all
allowed a goof
okay is that it I think we're done thank
you very much I closed the hearing on
the work session thanks so much
foreign